Saint Dirty Rap, you're on stage.
>> Yo. Yo, what's up?
>> What's up, man?
>> Can you hear me? I'm kind of lagging a
problem living in third world country.
>> I can hear you.
>> I I have a question. Uh like you said
Jesus was exist at the beginning with
God. So, did he claim he knows
everything during the life he has spent
the beginning?
>> Go ahead. And and what what is what is
your argument exactly? Just just go
straight to it.
>> I got out. Did I got out?
>> I guess. So,
>> did Jesus claim anything about the He
knows he have any memories about the
beginning of time when he was exist with
God?
>> Yeah. Yeah. He said that he saw Satan
fall like lightning when Satan was cast
out of heaven. Jesus says that he saw
him fall. He was there.
>> Okay. Uh like that's that's all that's
>> what he saw.
>> That's just one example.
>> Okay. U I'm actually from Iran. I don't
have any sources of uh gospel or or any
uh Christians sources like but I came to
faith as I start hearing voices in my
head that later on with the internet
comes out and we got information about
the Christianity. It claims that I I I
came to confirmation that God was
talking to me and God saved me kind of
like I heard voice voices about there
was three stars. They made whole reality
and one of them was me. It was as God
was speaking to me. One of them was you.
But you were not given life. You were
not giving death. And those speeches
were actually claiming that I'm the
Jesus and I'm I'm the God.
>> Abd Rahman, how you doing? You're on
stage.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yes, I can hear you.
>> Um, I actually want to say sorry to you
for one thing because I've seen it
multiple times that you just are in like
a 4hour stream keep hearing the same
question. I have to explain it the same
way. So, I want to apologize to that.
And I feel like sometimes it just comes
down to faith. So it just has nothing to
do with how much you show because I
believe that Jesus did some what was it
miracles in his time and people saw it
with their own eyes and still didn't
believe. So I feel like sometimes you
cannot just help people and they just
come here to argue, you know. So if
Muslims did that, I apologize for that.
And I feel like some people just
genuinely come here to argue and they
could say that upfront and I don't have
a problem with that. I don't feel like
you have a problem with that. But
saying, "Oh yeah, I want to learn about
this." But then come in the worst way
possible. I feel like that's just not a
good look for us. And yeah, so I just
wanted to start off by saying that. And
um yeah, my first question would be like
and before I even start like I feel like
your title is Jesus is the most high
God. change my mind. I feel like in that
structure, it's impossible for me as
someone who doesn't believe the religion
and you someone who genuinely believe
the religion for me to change your mind,
you know? So, I'm not here to change
your faith. I'm here to like ask you if
your faith aligns with what Jesus
actually said. If it doesn't, then maybe
the change of mind needs to start there.
So, and my first question or like my
first question would be before we talk
about who is God, let's like be clear on
what being God means. So, like just for
me to ask you, God by definition is
self-existent, right? All knowing and
independent, right?
>> Mhm.
>> So, can someone who says I can do
nothing by myself fit that definition?
>> Well, you got to say it in context. He
says the son can do nothing by himself
but only what he sees the father doing
or whatever the father does the son does
likewise. So in the full context we see
that Jesus is saying when he says the
son can do nothing of himself but only
what he sees the father doing means that
he doesn't work alone. He's not some
rogue ninja out there that just works
separately from the father. everything
he does is involved with the father and
vice versa. And they just said that
whatever the father does, the son does
likewise. So Jesus just said that he can
do whatever god can do. So he's showing
that he's actually all powerful in that
in that in that verse.
>> Wait, did you say that he says that he
can do only what the father can do? He
says he he says that he does only what
he sees the father doing
>> because whatever the father does the son
does it likewise. So he can do whatever
the father can do.
>> Okay. Thank you for that. Thank you for
explaining that. That was one of the
things that always confused me.
>> People usually only know like that first
part of the sentence. They
>> they're not familiar with the rest of
what Jesus says in that same verse. So
that's
19.
>> Yeah. I feel like that's on both sides.
Christianity and Muslim apologist. I
feel like Christian apologists don't
really learn about Islam that much and
they only try to find contra like
contradictions and the same thing for
Muslims. So this is vice versa. But
thank you for explaining to me that. And
my other question would be about what
about the people like let's say who were
alive at the time of Jesus and maybe
even saw him etc. So my question is what
about the people who didn't see the
resurrection like just like us or even
those who did see it but only held on to
Jesus's action words that he could do
nothing without God. And I feel like you
heard this a billion times but him
saying like for example the father is
greater than him and that the father is
the only true God and even after the
resurrection Jesus still said I am
ascending to my father and to your
father to my god and your god. So are
you saying those people who like
literally believed what Jesus himself
taught would be condemned? Because if so
like then according to your standard
even his earliest followers weren't
saved those who believed him like that.
So, and I'm not trying to say the
trinity was invented, but if it wasn't
clarified at first and it took nearly
what was it 300 before like the
counselors finally defined it, is it
like really fair to say that the
salvation depended on be or like
believing it the whole time? If it truly
was essential, then what about all of
those generations in between?
>> Okay. Um,
if what you were saying was the case,
then you would have a point that it
would be it wouldn't be fair for the
people to reject or get punished for not
believing that Jesus is God if he
clearly said that he's not. If if that
was the case, you would be right. But
it's not. He clearly communicated that
he's God. Even in those verses that you
point to, he he says that he's God. He
communicates that he's God. And the
trinity is seen not at the council of
Nika. They even talk about the trinity.
The trinity is seen in the old testament
even before Jesus comes to earth and is
born. We see the we see the trinity. The
father, son, and holy spirit, his word,
his spirit, the father. We see that in
the old testament. So did you want to go
over those verses that you mentioned?
The father's greater than I. Um what
else? I father, my god, your god. You
want to go over those?
>> Yes, please. All right. So, let's start
with John 14:28. Have you read that
verse?
>> Yes, I think so, but I don't remember it
fully. I just I just hopped on the knife
after, you know, it's like, what was
that almost 1:00 a.m. in Spain? So,
>> okay.
>> Where did you Where'd you get the verse
from? Where did you get the verse from,
John? When you said uh when you quoted
where Jesus says the father is greater
than I, where did you get that from?
>> I was talking to this one apologist guy
on Instagram. I texted you too, but I
feel like he didn't see it. So he was
the one who what was it mentioned that
verse to me. So that was the first time
I've ever heard it.
>> You're saying a m a Muslim apologist?
>> No, no, a Christian one.
>> Oh, so a Christian apologist showed you
that verse and
>> No, he didn't use it like in the way I'm
using it. But
>> but he just didn't explain it to me that
well when he did go over it.
>> Gotcha.
>> So if you can please do explain.
>> Okay, I got you.
>> So John 14 is where he's quoting.
>> Mhm.
John 14 and really um John 14 is a
amazing chapter to talk about the deity
of Christ to show that he's God. But
let's deal with the cuz what you're
quoting is verse 28 close to the end of
the chapter. Okay. I'm going to show you
we're going to talk about verse 28 and
then I'm going to show you how in the
other verses in the same chapter Jesus
shows that he's God cuz he says you can
pray to him. All right. Okay. So it says
here verse uh verse 27 and 28 peace I
leave with you my peace I give to you
not as the world gives do I give to you
let not your hearts be troubled neither
let them be afraid so first of all we
see Jesus saying
>> what verse is that
>> this is verse 27 this is right before
the verse that we're that you that you
brought up matter of fact look at verse
26 bro he says let me share it on the
screen so you can see verse 26 he says
but the helper, the Holy Spirit, whom
the Father will send in my name. He will
teach you all things and bring to your
remembrance all that I have said to you.
Why in the world is God sending or doing
something in somebody else's name?
>> Right? God doesn't have to do anything
in anybody else's name. He's God, right?
He does things in his own name. Right?
>> Unless Jesus is also God. If Jesus is
also God, then this makes sense. This
doesn't make sense if Jesus is a
creature for the father to be doing
something in his name. In a prophet's
name, a creature's name. That makes no
sense. All right? So, this is what Jesus
is saying. Jesus is saying God is going
to send the Holy Spirit in my name. God
is doing something in my name. Right?
And he goes on to say, watch this. Peace
I leave with you. My peace I give to
you. Wait, hold on a second. Who's the
one who's supposed to be giving peace?
Abd Rahman. God.
>> Who gives God? Exactly. But Jesus is
saying, "I give you peace. My peace I
give to you. Not as the world gives do I
give to you." So, not only do we have
Jesus saying that the father will send
do something in his name, but he also
says that he's the source of peace. He's
the one who gives peace.
>> Mhm.
>> Does it sound like somebody who believes
he's just a mirror a mere creature, a
mere prophet?
>> I will I will let you finish.
I I'm asking so far does this sound like
somebody who believes that they are a
mere prophet, a mere creature?
>> Well, like in my like opinion again,
>> your opinion. Your opinion basically.
>> Yeah. Like just because something is
done like let's say in Jesus's name,
that doesn't mean like Jesus is God.
Like humans,
>> whose name do we do things in?
>> Wait, let me finish. Let me finish. Like
>> humans can act in someone else's name
without being that person. Like the
similar like when you use Jesus can send
peace as a messenger or agent of God
without being fully defined himself. So
>> that's nowhere in scripture.
>> Huh?
>> That's nowhere in scripture. That's
nowhere in the Quran or the Bible where
a messenger can uh bestow peace on
someone. They're the source of the peace
that they give. No, it's always the pe
they pray for peace from God on people,
right? They're not they themselves are
not the giver of peace. Wouldn't you
agree with that?
>> Well, like don't we say in like as
Muslims like for example
like peace, right? So like
>> yeah who's who's peace
talking about Jesus? What was that?
>> Yeah. When when you sayalamlaykum whose
peace are you asking are you hoping that
is bestowed on the person that you're
greeting? Is it your peace?
>> God's peace. Right.
>> Right. Never do you say my peace I give
I bestow on you. No. You ask for God's
peace to bestowed on a person. Jesus
says it's my peace that I give to you.
Right.
>> Mhm.
>> That would be sherk in Islam.
>> So right here we see that Jesus is uh
declaring divine prerogatives. He's
claiming to be God even with what he
orders and says. He's communicating that
he's not just a mere prophet, but that
he's God, the source of peace, the one
who gives peace.
>> But hasn't there ever like hasn't there
been prophets before who exactly said
what God said without them? Like like
basically
>> No, they always say thus says the Lord.
Always. They always says thus says the
Lord. Here's another thing to think
about.
>> In in most of the chapters, from what
you know, how do most of the chapters in
the Quran start off with?
>> I'm not sure cuz I read it in Arabic.
Bismah.
>> You mean like
>> Exactly. Exactly. Bismah. What does
bismillah mean?
>> Basically,
I don't know Arabic, but is it like
>> It means It means in the name of Allah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. In the name of Allah.
>> In the name of Allah. That's how the
majority of the Quran uh chapters begin.
In the name of Allah. Right. Everything
you do is in the name of Allah. You
perform salat in the name of Allah. You
commit jihad in the name of Allah. You
struggle for your faith in the name of
Allah. Everything you do, you give
charity in the name of Allah. You honor
in your mother, your parents, give good,
do good to the poor, all of this in the
name of Allah. Right.
>> Mhm.
>> You wouldn't do you wouldn't say in the
name of Muhammad or in the name of
Jabriel, would you?
>> Mhm. But I'm not a prophet. Again,
though,
>> would a would a prophet would a prophet
say, "Do these things in my name?" Would
Muhammad say, "Hey, go uh perform salat
in in my name. Biz me biz me M Muhammad
could you do could you say that and
could could Muhammad say that
>> no
>> exactly why cuz it'll be sherk right
it'll be blaspheming associating himself
with Allah so no prophet can ever say
this
>> no no prophet can ever say this but
Jesus says that the father will send the
spirit in my name that demonstrates that
Jesus it's now notice it's not just a
prophet or you know a believer that's
doing something in the name of Jesus,
it's the father, the heavenly father is
sending doing an action in the name of
the son. in the name of Jesus.
>> Okay. Okay. Now that makes sense to me
obviously, but some would argue more
about this, but just because like Yeah.
Yeah. Obviously, because in my faith, we
already don't believe in the verses that
don't align with our framework, you
know? So, I could Yeah. So, I could just
throw this away by saying, "Oh, yeah,
but we don't believe in."
>> But you But you can't because remember
you wait just really quick. I don't mean
to cut you off, but you weren't making
an argument. based off of what you're
saying in the Quran or what the Quran
say.
>> That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm
saying. So right now I'm trying to
understand your guy's point of view and
that's
>> So right now I understood your guy's
point of view.
>> Now I have an question about what was
it? If one person it's about Jesus again
if one person has two complete wills
divine and human right which one made
decisions? So the person makes
decisions. The person not like wills
don't make decisions. Persons do
according to their will. And so with
Jesus having a divine will and a human
will, he brings the human will under
subjection to the divine will.
>> Okay. But when he said not my will but
yours, was that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. The father's will that he
the the will the father's will, the
divine will that he shares with the
father, he brings the human will into
under subjection to the father's will.
The divine will. Which what do you mean
by that? I'm a bit confused.
>> So you have Jesus who has two he has two
natures. Divine nature and a human
nature which means he has two wills a
divine will and a human will. The divine
nature he shares with the father.
Meaning the divine will he shares with
the father. Right? But he also has a
human will that you know uh can be
grieve you know grieved and you know
feel despair and he can go through all
these things right. He brings the human
will under subjection under submission
to the divine will. He aligns it with
the divine will.
>> Mhm.
>> That he shares with the father. That's
why he can say not my will but your will
be done. Not my will. Meaning the human
will that he possesses but
>> the divine will be done. Your will be
done that he shares with them.
>> But if two beings are equal,
>> two persons
>> like Yeah. Okay. two persons if they are
equal in my opinion neither should be
subordinate to the other but like in
every instance the father commands sends
or speak to the son while the son obeys
prays and what was it or like submits
how can they be like equal under this
pattern why is the father never
>> because you can be equal in one sense
and you know you know subjected or a
servant in another sense
So, for example, do you do you have a
job?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Okay. You got a boss or are you in
your own boss?
>> I got a boss.
>> Oh, you got a boss. Okay, cool. Maybe
one day you'll be your own boss, man.
But for now, you got a boss, right? Now,
at work, your boss is greater than you,
right? Cuz they're your boss. You submit
to your boss. They are the authority
over you, right?
>> Mhm.
>> But you and your boss are both human.
You're both equal in that you're human,
right?
>> Yes. So you're equal in one sense and
that you're both human. You have the
same equal value as human beings. But in
the workplace, you submit to your boss
as your authority. And so in the
workplace, he's greater than you in
authority, not greater than you in
essence or your nature as humans. So
you're equal in your nature, but you
take a humble employee role to your
boss. So he's greater than you in one
sense while you guys are equal in
another sense. Right? So similarly with
Jesus and the father, Jesus and the
father are equal in their essence.
They're one being, one God. They have
the same exact essence. Right? That's
how they're equal. However, Jesus takes
the servants's role. He humbles himself
to the father. And so in that way, in
that sense, the father is greater than
him in in that role because Jesus serves
him. He submits himself to him. Right?
>> So they're equal in one sense in the
sense of their essence. They say the
same divine essence, same nature as the
one God, but Jesus humbles himself and
um subjects himself to the father.
>> Okay, make sense?
>> Yes, that does that does in a way. I've
never got this point of view ever. I've
asked I feel like this question
different people and they always go to
something that just doesn't make sense.
And when I ask a question about it, they
just say that I'm either being ignorant
or and just something else. just maybe
stubborn or dishonest or something.
>> Yeah. So, can I ask you like one more
question and just
>> keep going, man. Keep going. Look, I'm
I'm here to serve you, man. I'm I'm here
to serve.
>> Okay. This is my last question because I
feel like there are other people waiting
here right now.
>> After you, I'mma end it. I'm I'm going
call it a day. I've been live almost
four hours, man. So,
>> thank you, man. So my last question
would be if what was the people's
eternal destiny is on the line in my
opinion
>> God would not send for example like
flawed or like flawed I mean like people
are doing like let's say mistakes or
like big mistakes major sins for example
and so like morally failing prophets
right to represent God's message in my
opinion he would send the best humanity
the best And in that time where people
was living at or whatever it was so it
can be fully reliable in character and
in message people attack Islam for what
was it for our prophet peace be upon him
right marrying Aisha calling him a
pedophile without understanding the
historical or the cultural context. You
get it?
You're saying that you're saying that's
listen we can talk about that next if
you want but that's a whole another
subject you know so I don't want to jump
from this is just an example it's just
an example you know so
>> okay
>> people make an argument about that right
to show that what was it Muhammad is not
a true prophet right
>> but they accept stories of prophet or
like prophets committing what was it
>> adultery and yeah
>> yeah murder and drunkenness in the
Bible.
>> Yep.
>> So, in my opinion, that's just
inconsistent and not fair.
>> It would be inconsistent if it was if
that was what was happening, but that's
not
>> there. There's a there's a little part
you're missing. Okay. Um the difference
is is that do you do you know how uh
Muhammad said that he came to even the
idea to marry Aisha? So the in the
hadith he says that Allah showed Aisha
to him in a dream and that's how he
determined like okay I should marry her.
Basically he's saying God told me so
right.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. The difference with that and let's
say prophet David who committed murder
and adultery basically with Uriah and
his wife Bethsheba or Noah getting drunk
or Abraham lying. or you know anything.
>> None of them ever said, "God told me to
do this. God said this was okay." In
fact, you'll see when David, for
example, when he comes to realization
that he was wrong, he immediately fasted
and repented. And you'll see his entire
repentance in the Psalm 51. It's in the
Psalm. Um God condemns these actions
from these said prophets who do these
actions. He condemns them for this. God
checked Abraham when he lied. Okay. Um,
he checks the wrongdoer. Muhammad said,
"God told me this was okay." That's the
difference. So,
>> I was Okay. The thing is like I would
love to keep talking about this, but do
you want to go to that subject and we
could just let this be because I feel
like it's still
>> Yeah. Okay. We can we can talk about
that.
>> Yeah, let's let's talk about it. Let let
this be the last subject. And then
>> and by the way, dude, I I go live every
Monday, Wednesday, Friday, same time.
You can come anytime and ask questions,
okay? You can come anytime. All right.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. So, yeah, let's let's talk
about it.
>> Okay. But I I mean like I'm going to
talk about it. I'm not going to I'm not
like I I've seen some clips of you
talking to people about this. I'm not
going to dodge it. But like my point
still stands. Let's say there's an
unbeliever, right? And what was it? Was
it Loots or David's time? I'm not sure.
And where what was it? One of them did
insist, right? Let's say a prophet comes
in your time. There's no phone. There's
nothing else that you have right now
other than what was it what people say,
right? There's this one prophet says,
"I'm set by God and I'm supposed to
teach you what was how to be or like how
to get in heaven." Right? People say,
"Okay." They listen to him, yada yada
yada. Then they hear that he slept with
his daughter. If there is a whole
people's or like let's say there are
thousands of people because I feel like
there wasn't some like every prophet had
their own what was it purpose and
mission and there wasn't said to the
whole world but if there's like let's
say a couple thousands people's
what was it eternity on the line would
they go to heaven or hell and there is a
man what was it who does incest wouldn't
that make them what was it lose trust in
him in your opinion right now if If
there was like let's say a prophet,
right? And he heard that he did
something unfathomable. He slept with
his own daughter, right? Would it be
crazy for you to reject everything else
he says? Because people try to find
everything and anything to reject a
prophet?
>> If you know,
>> if the prophet says, "God told me to do
this sinful action," and justifies it by
saying, "God told me this is okay." Then
yes, I reject him and know that he's a
false prophet. And by the way, Lot
wasn't a prophet and he was a victim. He
was drunken by his daughters and then
got got raped. But as far as um just
just like this is my position, brother,
if there's somebody claiming to be a
prophet, committing a sinful action and
justifying it by saying, "God justifies
this. This is okay." I know that that's
a false prophet cuz God never justifies
sin. So, you're saying that you would
still trust him even if you heard that,
let's say, he what was it? Took
someone's wife and killed her husband.
Just
>> I would trust I I can still trust him
when I see that he's open about his sin
and repents to God about it. Doesn't say
God justified this action, but that God
punished me for this. That's a
trustworthy prophet. Someone who's
honest and transparent like that. Not
someone who hides their sin under the
guise of God told me so. God told me to
do this.
>> You You understand the difference?
>> Mhm.
>> So that's that's huge for me.
>> Okay. But that's you. But this would
just get along. But let's just get to
the what was it?
>> Wait. But don't don't you think that
that's a good position to have that that
a prophet should not sin and then
therefore say, "God told me to do this
sin." Right? No prophet, no true prophet
of God would sin and say, "God told me
to sin. God told me to do this." Right.
>> Mhm.
>> So that's
>> So you believe Okay. Okay. Yes. I
understand 100%. Yes.
>> Okay.
>> So you believe that what was it?
Muhammad what was it did a sin by
marrying Aisha and he said God told me
so.
>> Yes.
>> Why wasn't there any what was it Jews at
the time or any of the people who was
against it? What was it? What was it?
Our prophet. Why didn't they go against
it? Why didn't they criticize him for
that? cuz they criticized him for a lot
of things, but that was not one of them.
>> Well, I think that um that's just an
argument from silence, bro. Just because
we don't have, let's say, uh an exact
source that says somebody brought that
as a criticism doesn't mean nobody did.
That's just an argument from silence.
And then two, who cares if if nobody
brought this up? That doesn't make it
right. Like like if if somebody if if
somebody grapes someone, right, and
nobody nobody condemned him for it.
Nobody brought this up as a condemnation
against him and critique against him.
Does that mean that him graing the
person was okay?
>> Yeah, but that's not the same thing in
this situation though.
>> What's so what you're you're saying that
it's okay.
>> Give it a girl, a little girl.
>> No, no, no. I'm not saying that. But
this is not like the same situation that
you're comparing. But it's just like
you're comparing someone getting raped
and there's not a single person in the
whole community that says, "Oh, that's
wrong." That's like a hypothetical
situation. You're putting me in like a
box where I cannot get out of.
Obviously, there's nobody what was it
there? There will be never a situation
where there is what was it thousands of
thousands of people in a place and
someone gets raped and everybody just
gets quiet about it.
>> I disagree. I disagree because you know
you have a lot of people that have great
culture um and then nobody says anything
about it because one the people are in
power and they can get in trouble for
going against that person um stat social
status can be jeopardized for bringing
these criticisms against this person and
so um you know there's a lot of there's
a lot of reasons why somebody would
would suppress that and again I it it
doesn't matter if people bring it up as
an objection or not in that community.
You get what I'm saying?
>> Yes. But the life expenses back then
wasn't like it was literally a different
time.
>> So you're saying that the I know. So,
you're saying in that time it was okay
for a grown adult man, a 56-y old man to
marry a 6-year-old
child who's still playing with dolls and
then sleep with her at 9 years old still
playing with dolls. You're saying that
at that time culturally that was okay,
right?
>> No. But no, but did he ever get her
pregnant?
>> No. No, no, no. Listen, listen. gen
think about it. Think about it. Think
about it. Think about it. Listen. If the
life expectancy back then was 30 years,
right? Listen. If the life expectancy
back then was 30 years, right? Listen.
And
>> the life expectancy was not 30. That's a
lie. Muhammad was lived he was 56. Uh
Umar was older than that. Uh uh Abu Bakr
lived older than that.
>> No, I'm not talking about everybody died
at 30. I'm saying that most people died
before the age of 30 in that. No, they
didn't. No, they didn't.
>> You can look it up right now. Look it up
right now.
>> Okay, I got you. So, so just really
quick, let me go with you. So, life
expectancy is 30. You're telling me that
it's okay, let's say even today that the
life expectancy of man kind was 30 years
old, right? Across the across the world
or whatever. You're telling me that then
that would mean that today in a in a in
a world where 30 years is the
expectancy, someone who lives to be 56,
it's okay for that 56 year old man to
sleep with a 9-year-old little girl.
>> I believe as of right now it's haram.
Like it's
>> you believe now it's haram. It's as of
right because I I feel like one thing
that nobody ever said to you is because
in Islam every woman is judged
individually. So it's not like what was
it in Europe that let's say one country
says that every woman can marry when
they're 14 or 18 or 21.
>> It's every woman is judged individually.
Is he is she ready mentally?
>> I got you. So, so you, so you're telling
me that there can be a 9-year-old little
girl who is mentally and physically and
emotionally ready for sexual
intercourse. You think that that's
possible? Playing with God.
>> Trying to go against that age?
>> Wait, so you are you audi?
>> Yes, I am.
>> How can you go against the age when all
of your sudi sources say she was nine?
>> No. Okay, I can explain it to you.
>> Okay.
>> Do we believe as Muslims that humans can
be wrong? Do you believe that your
sources are wrong? I would just want to
know. Just
>> No, I'm not talking about sources. I'm
not talking about I'm talking about
Aisha herself.
>> Oh, Aisha could have been wrong about
her own age.
>> Yes. Let me let me let me explain it to
you. Let me explain. I feel like you
heard this before.
>> I I I have. So, so just to be clear,
Aisha, the mother of the believers, the
young scholar herself who recorded so
many hadith with wisdom and good memory,
couldn't remember her age.
>> Okay. Can I make my argument about why I
believe that she was wrong about it?
Give me two minutes. Give me two
minutes.
>> You got it.
>> First, you know that her older sister
was 10 years older there, right?
>> I I don't know.
>> Okay. Her older sister's name is Asma.
She was 10 years older than her. Asthma
died 73 years after the Hijra. So, at
that time, she was 100 years old. So she
was around what was it 20 oh like she
was born around 27 years before the
hijra right so Aisha's birth what was it
17 years before the what was it hijra so
about year 67 in your calendar right
that makes her 17 years old at the hijra
and 20 when the marriage was consummated
so and another thing I'd like to talk
about is what was it
Like have you heard
where he's talking about the first
believers or like the first Muslims and
who became Muslim. So he includes Isisha
among those Abu Bakr what was it who he
called to Musl what was it Islam in the
first years of revelation.
>> Got 30 seconds.
>> Okay. If true she would have been old
enough to accept Islam consciously.
Right. Impossible if she was born after
year 610
right she said when surah al the moon
right was revealed I was a young girl
surah al was revealed around year 65
only four years after first revelation
remembered it she must have been least
at least 68
okay all right so with all this being
said you want me to believe. You want me
to believe that Aisha, Bkari, every
single person that narrated Aisha and
his and and her marriage with Muhammad
um
Aisha saying that she was playing with
dolls. You want me to believe that all
of them are wrong for this conspiracy?
>> It's not conspiracy though. You can look
this up.
>> Do any of your sources, your Sunni
sources say anything different in
regards to when Aisha was consummated?
>> Yes. It's not even like as of right now,
but yes, they do talk about it.
>> No, no. I mean, my here's my question,
brother.
>> Is there any sahi narration or authentic
toughs that says that Aisha was other
than 9 years old when she was
consummated?
>> No.
>> So, do you understand my my dilemma?
Everything within Sunni Islam that is of
the most authentic, the most
authenticity says she was nine when
Muhammad slept with her and that she was
playing with dolls still. You see, I I
so I I have to if I'm I'm a I'm a I'm an
honest thinker, I have to go with the
evidence and the and the mountain of
authentic sources within the Islamic
framework. Not me. According to Islam,
these are the most authentic sources and
all of them are unanimous that she was
nine when he consummated with her. I
can't go against that, you know.
>> So right now if what was it, you know,
like the narrations or like what sah is
about is did the prophet or did the what
was the sahabas or like the followers of
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam at that time did they truly say
that? That's the whole point of what was
the isnad is about. That's why every
person who talked about it is verified.
So if one what was it what was it the
follower of prophet Muhammad said that
what was it something happened in that
and in that year and there has been many
cases where what was it Aisha for
example when I was talking about and
when she said surah al was revealed when
I was a young girl. So surah al was
around and this is a fact again surah al
was revealed around year 614.
So only four years after the first
revelation if she remembered it she must
have have been 6 and 8 at the time born
around 606
and 608.
>> You see you see you see the mountain of
gymnastics that you guys got to do bro
like I I I couldn't imagine being in
your position. I really couldn't like in
order to defend what my prophet did like
I I'm just like thinking like if man if
Jesus did something like this I would
have to do what you're doing I would
have to you know come up with things
okay you know Aisha the mother of
believers she maybe she was wrong she
didn't know her own age um you know all
of the narrators they were wrong who all
of the uh uh sahi graders they were
wrong all of the commentators like and
all the classical exedites they were
wrong all so now guess what you have to
throw the entire hadith corpus under the
bus because you can't trust your most
authentic sources that that were nobody
disagrees with in your religion. So now
Islam is in shambles. Now I I can't
trust the hadith when it talks about the
Quran. I can't talk I can't trust the
hadith when it talks about Muhammad. No,
no. Again, this is this is where you're
like changing and like you're putting me
in a box again. This is what I'm talking
about.
>> I No, this is good. This is good. Let me
talk for one minute.
>> The box is Islam. Look, this is Islam.
That's the box that you're in. I'm not
doing it. You're a Muslim. So, you are
born in the box, bro. You're born here.
>> Well, I don't know how long you've been
a Muslim.
>> Like my whole life.
>> Yeah. So your whole life you've been
right here in this box. I'm just show
I'm just opening the box, reaching my
hand down saying, "Come on out, man.
Come on out of the box, bro."
>> All right. Can I talk? One thing I
noticed about you is like, let's say I
tell you something, right? Or I tell you
my point of view. You don't say, "Hold
on, give me a second and let me look at
it." Every year that I mentioned, right,
you didn't say, "Hold on, one second,
let me look at it." you just it feels
like you're doing the exact same thing
that the people who come on this live do
to you. It's like if you show people a
new point of view and obviously all
those and everybody
>> I'm not saying that they was lying. They
was not wrong. I'm not saying that Aisha
was lying or anything. I'm saying that
if I remembered wrong and what was it?
Everybody who narrated that you're
saying it wrong. How does that make what
was it Bkari or everybody else what was
it untrustable if they
>> I got you let me let me tell you how let
me let me tell you how sah what does
sahi mean you know
>> like it's authenticated
>> right that means that the information is
true the source is true
>> the person who like she did say it again
you're not this is this is what I mean
by you did not look this up enough to
know what it means obviously
>> so something can be si but the
information be false
>> in what sense? Like if you're talking
about what the prophet said, is that
what you mean? Like if the prophet said,
"Oh, if someone said, "Oh, yeah, I saw
the prophet, let's say, doing charity in
Sah, right? Bkari." Does that mean that,
oh yeah, that's false? You're like
literally comparing two different
things.
>> I'll ask you again, brother. I'll ask
you again. Can something be sahi and the
content of that sahi narration be false?
>> No.
>> Thank you. So sah when something is sahi
authentic it's not just yeah it's true
the person said it it's that what
they're saying is true the content is
true you can't say uh something is sahi
if the content is false that's why
things would be naive or something you
know or uh strange you know there will
be some type of something wrong with the
hadith they wouldn't make sahi the sahi
grading sahi means that the chain is
good and the content is good bro
>> okay
>> so you Well, let me let me just finish
on why I I paused there, but let me let
me just finish. Sorry, that was a long
weird pause. Let me show you why um this
would backfire on like Bkari and
everybody else. Because this narration
is is part of the sahi, the authentic
narration. It's the authentic Hadith
unanimously. It's it's authentic
everywhere in jammed in Sai Bkari in Sai
Muslim in Sunnasai in uh Sunn and Abu
Dawoud in in all of these hadith it's
sahi and these are the the top six
collections of hadith right if that if
the content of those authentic hadith if
that's questionable if that's false then
everything else is questionable when
something as unanimous as Aisha's age
>> Mhm. is questionable and in doubt even
though it's given the authentic grading
then everything else is questionable and
you should be in doubt of you should be
worried cuz now everything is out is is
out of order and in array you can't
trust anything that the huge corpus of
hadith there's thousands of them you
can't trust it you know
>> something now without getting
interrupted
>> sure
>> okay I'm going to explain to you like I
feel like I did not explain it to you
well what sah means right but I'm going
to try to explain to you one more time.
And if you don't get it, I feel like
it's damn near 2:00 a.m. for me that we
should just end it right here and I
could come back another day, you know?
>> How about this? How about this?
>> Can I explain it to you before we can
go?
>> You don't need to explain what sahi is
to me. I know what sahi is, dude.
>> No. Okay. Listen, let me let me just
explain to you why you're wrong about it
for once.
>> Wrong about what?
>> Let me just explain, please. Let me just
explain. All right.
>> I think we should just go to the Quran.
Listen
in hadith terminology right means the
chain of narrators and text is reliable.
It does not automatically mean every
detail is historically and fact like was
it factually verified exactly as stated.
So like like scholars right Islam
scholars right
>> you don't you don't got you you don't
got to explain it even even more. I
understand what you're saying.
>> They like they difference it between
and exact historical.
>> It's okay. Abd Rahman,
>> let me talk. Just give me one minute.
Say,
>> I don't I don't need that. Look, I I
need you to know who you're talking to.
I'm not a dummy and I'm not a rookie in
Islam. I know your religion. I know what
sahi means. If you want to take this
route that sahi isn't always
trustworthy, go ahead, be my guest.
Matter of fact, I agree with you.
>> What if this was in the Quran? What if
it was in the Quran that you can sleep
with little girls? Then what?
>> What you mean?
>> What if the Quran taught and permitted
that it was okay to sleep with little
girls? Then what?
>> That cannot be argued against that
cannot be said. The same way the same
way y'all don't go against Jesus's exact
teachings, but y can interpret what was
it the gospels, right? and said this if
you take this face value
>> like if you take this at face value
>> it's obviously wrong but that does not
make the
>> what was that like the gospel or like
Jesus not a messiah or something or like
not god so
>> okay so if if if the Quran taught let me
just ask you just straight up is it
morally okay to sleep with girls
prepubesscent girls immature girls is it
is it morally is it morally okay
>> no
>> good if a book claiming to be from God
taught that it was okay to sleep with
little girls, immature girls, then we
would know that that book is not from
God. Right.
>> Keep going.
>> Is that correct? I I need to know if
that's correct.
>> Get to your point. Like I'm not going to
obviously say something before you don't
even go to the point. So just go to
>> this is what this is what happened.
>> I will answer your question. I will I
swear to God I will say yes or no, but I
want you to get
>> So I need So I need I need a yes or no
before I go to my point.
>> Why?
>> If a book from God or a book claiming to
be from God, sorry. If a book claiming
to be from God taught that it was okay
to sleep and have relations with little
girls, immature girls, would that
demonstrate that that book is actually
not from God?
>> Yes. If he said that if you can sleep
with immature little girls, then yes.
>> Awesome. Okay. Now, I'm going to show
you my point. Okay. Okay. Yeah. It's
chapter 65 verse 4 of the Quran. Right.
>> What did you say?
>> What?
>> Chapter chapter what? Chapter 65:E4. I
have it on the screen. Can you see it?
>> Is it too small?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. You can see it. Okay. Now 654
it says, "And those who no longer expect
ministration among your women," meaning
those who are too old to ministrate. If
you doubt, then their period is 3
months. And also for those who have not
ministrated, so they have the same
period, uh the same waiting period is 3
months. All right? And for those who are
pregnant, their term is until they give
birth. And whoever fears Allah, he will
make for them for him of his matter
ease. So this verse, we'll break it
down. It gives you three categories of
females. And it's talking about divorce.
Okay, that's the chapter name, divorce.
>> So when you divorce your wives, it's
talking about three categories of women.
The ones who are too old to menrate,
>> the ones who have not yet ministrated,
and the ones who are pregnant. So the
old, the young, and the pregnant. Okay.
It's it's saying giving you how you are
to handle their divorcing them. All
right. Their waiting period, the ida,
have you ever heard of what the ida is
or their waiting period?
>> No, I didn't heard what the word either,
but I
>> Okay. So the so the waiting period or
the ida is the amount of time that a
woman has to wait before she's lawful to
move on to another man after getting
divorced where another man can marry
her. is to make sure that she's not
pregnant. Okay? So, for example, when we
go to chapter 33:49, it breaks this down
really, really quick, easy little verse.
It says, "Oh, you who believed, when you
marry believing women and then divorced
them before you have touched them,
meaning before you've had intercourse
with them, right? You didn't consate the
marriage. If you're divorcing them
before you have touched them, then there
is not for you any period. There's no
IDA to count concerning them.
>> They don't have to wait.
>> Right? If you didn't have sex with them,
they can just move on. But if you did,
then they have to wait to make sure
they're not pregnant. Make sense?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. So, here's the problem. In 654,
there's two women that have a waiting
period or two categories of women that
have a waiting period. The older ones
who don't expect to ministrate anymore
cuz they're too old to ministrate. And
the young ones who have not even
menrated yet. They haven't had their
puberties yet.
>> Mhm.
>> They're they're being divorced and they
have a waiting period, meaning that
their husbands slept with them. They
were touched.
>> What did you say? I said that they have
them having a waiting period means that
their husbands slept with them
>> because right cuz uh you don't have a
waiting period if you if your husband
didn't sleep with you. So this verse is
teaching that it's lawful to marry sleep
with and also divorce girls even before
they hit puberty before they
ministrated.
>> Just to show you that I'm not making
this up. Let's go to some scholars.
Let's go to Ibek. Have you heard of
Ibadir?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. one of the most famous scholars in
Sunni Islam. He says the ida the ida of
those in menopause menopause means those
who are too old to menrate and those who
do not have menes meaning they're too
young. Watch. Allah the exalted
clarifies the waiting period of the
woman in menopause and that is the one
whose ministration has stopped due to
her older age. Mhm.
>> Her ida is 3 months instead of the three
monthly cycles for those who menrate
which is based on chapter 28. 228. Watch
this. The same for the young who have
not reached the years of ministration.
Their ida is 3 months like those in
menopause.
This is the meaning of his saying and
for those who have no courses or those
who have not ministrated. So even the
understanding of the scholars is that
the Quran is teaching that you can
marry, sleep with and divorce. Thank you
sweetheart. Girls, immature girls even
before they've reached the age of
ministrating.
>> So with the Quran teaching that it's
okay to sleep with little girls,
immature girls, we know that there's no
way that the Quran is a book from God.
You understand?
>> Yeah. Oh, if I'm not like mistaken, I
feel like I've gone through this when I
was basically learning about the Quran
too cuz I've been studying it
consistently for the last four or five
years. So in the ayah Quran or like the
Quran and what was that did you say
chapter 65 verse4 right?
>> Yes.
>> Like it mentions a waiting period as you
talked about that right?
>> That's right. All wives after divorce
including girls who didn't what was it
who hadn't yet menstruated right but
this doesn't mean they were what was it
active the rule was meant to protect
legal rights what was a an inheritance
and clarity in the case what was a the
marriage was consummated later so in the
historical context girls could be
married as you know young under their
parents parents guardianship what what
was a consummation I don't know how to
say the word but like the consummation I
think you know what I'm talking about
was often as you know delayed until they
was or like were mature so today
>> the Quran doesn't say that bro
>> huh
>> look at what the Quran says remember I
showed you this verse this this is why I
pulled up the second verse over here on
the left chapter 33:49 maybe maybe you
wasn't um paying attention when I read
this look oh you who have believed
When you marry believing women and then
divorce them before you have touched
them, then there is no waiting period to
concern concerning them. There is no ida
unless you had sex with the with your
wife.
>> Mhm.
>> The only time you have an ida is if your
husband slept with you.
>> So these little
>> Yeah. Go ahead.
>> The only time you have ida is when you
have been slept with.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. meaning that these little girls
were slept with. They were sexually
active because they have an ida. They
have a waiting period.
>> Can I look up that ayah and read it?
>> Yep. Which one? 30 3349 about the
waiting period.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That one. That one.
>> Yep. Yep. Chapter 33:49. You can read
Arabic.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Because I
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. I can uh I can
pull it up in Arabic for you. There it
is. Hold on. Let me make it smaller. So,
>> there you go. Yeshua.
>> Okay.
So right now I'll talk about both verses
because first I talked about the first
one. So again the first ayah was as you
know talking about the waiting period
even for women who hasn't menrated yet
and I feel like we did talk about that.
So in historical context right and this
is is you know important in the 7th
century Arabia girls could be married I
don't know you know this but let me
finish girls could be married under
guardianship at a young age but them
getting consummated and moving in with
the man etc was often delayed until they
reach physical maturity right the Quran
re was like regulated marriage practices
including divorces periods etc right So
this verse the chapter 33:49
it's talking about ethical treatment of
women what was it during the divorce or
particularity or whatever I don't know
the exact word but
>> brother according to the verse here do
you have an ida if you didn't have sex
with your husband
>> no
>> okay according to this verse over here
the young girls who are haven't
mistrated yet do they have an ida
>> yes it seems like them
>> it doesn't seem like it explicitly says
It says their waiting period is 3
months. They have an end up. So that
means that their husband slept with
them, right? According to the Quran,
>> yes.
>> So this means that the Quran is teaching
that it is permissible to sleep with
girls even before they matured and
divorced them. There's no way around it,
brother. There's no way to justify this.
This is this is I have to be real with
you. This is disgusting. I have to be
honest. And I and I know that you have
to ask you the same thing.
>> I will look up this I will look up this
verse, but I want you to look up one
thing, too. And I would just say it as
short as we can. I can and we can just
stop this. You know, you can look this
up if you think I'm lying. But applies
even if a marriage isn't consummated.
So what was it? The you're talking about
in 65, what was it? Verse four doesn't
mean like girls who didn't menstruate or
like they didn't get their periods yet
were being slept with. It was a legal
rule to protect rights. And today Islam
requires maturity and consent for
marriage. So if you if you don't want to
like take that, you can look it up and
you can literally hear millions of
scholars explaining it and you're just
exactly the same thing that Muslims do
to the Bible taking it as face value.
They're not reading that.
>> No, there's there's a difference between
what I'm doing and what Muslims do. What
I'm doing
>> I feel like you don't even know. Do you
know the basics of Islam? What what I've
what I've shown Abdul Rahman is what is
completely different from what you
Muslims do. Not let me not say you
Muslims because you listened but what I
normally get from Muslims. They will
take a verse out of context. They won't
even go to the scholars and the church
fathers and the commentary. They will
they will rip a verse out of context and
then try to make an argument based off
that. What I did is I put I used the
Quran in its context and I gave the taps
on the verse showing that it wasn't me
making this up but the scholars are
saying exactly what I'm saying. That's
the difference. So
>> So are you saying that scholars explain
that verse in the way that you do?
>> Yeah. I just showed you IAT there,
didn't I? Matter of fact, yeah. You want
to see what scholars say? So they say
explicitly that you can marry a woman
before she gets hurt.
>> Yeah, I just showed you I just showed
you Ibath just said that. I show Were
you not paying attention, brother?
Didn't I show you on the screen Ibath
breaking it down, saying exactly what I
said?
>> Can I take a picture of it? Can you show
it again?
>> Sure. Of course. I'm here to serve, man.
Whatever you need.
>> And I feel like I should just come back
another day and we can either keep going
on from here or I can learn something
new.
>> Of course, bro. We we can pick this back
up if you want to come back again and we
could talk about other things as well.
Um but ne we can definitely pick this
back up next time we talk. All right.
Here let me Oh, sorry. Hold on. Let me
um let me actually do it like this.
There you go.
>> Okay. Okay. Now I took a picture.
>> All right.
>> So I hope that I can talk to you next
Monday or what did you say every Mondays
and Fridays?
>> Monday, Wednesday, Friday. You can come
any of those days, man.
>> I will come in those days. And the last
thing I would like to finish with is
like the way I understand it right now,
I feel like I will understand in a
different way when I come back in Monday
and do more research about it.
>> But the way I understand it right now is
like imagine a law in a country says all
citizens must serve a waiting period
before leaving the office, right? Even
if they never actually held office. So
no one would assume that this means the
people were actually in office. It's
just the legal rule covering or was it
everyone in case they were. So similarly
the Quran in chapter 65:4 gives a
waiting period it says for all wives
even girls who haven't menrated yet. So
it does not mean girls who didn't
menrate yet we're being sexually active.
It's a legal rule to protect rights.
Right. Just as I explained earlier
>> but you're missing an important detail.
It it Yeah, you're right. is saying for
all wives.
>> Important detail.
>> The the the the qualifier is if you did
not touch her. That's the qualifier. If
you did not touch her, bro, hold on. Let
me let me make it nice and big so that
we don't miss it. Let me let me uh
if you divorce them before you touch
them.
>> Mhm.
>> You see that? That's that's the
important part right there. It's not
just saying, "Oh, every believing woman
has an ida." No, every believing woman
has an ida unless you did not touch her.
So, screen screenshot this too. I want
you to screenshot this, too, so you can
get this. That right there is the
important part.
>> What hadith is that? The exact one that
you're showing me right now. The
>> verse is chapter 33:49. Chapter 33:49.
>> Okay. So according to the Quran, you
only have an EDA if your husband slept
with you. The verse says that
explicitly. That's not something we have
to interpret into it, think about it,
make it up. The verse explicitly,
verbatim says when you're divorcing them
before you touch them, then they don't
have an.
>> So all right, uh, let's go ahead and
call it. I definitely appreciate this
this conversation, man. Um, you was a
pleasant guest to have to end on, man.
You wasn't no, you know, you wasn't like
the others as you said. So, I appreciate
you, bro.
>> All right, man. I don't know if it's an
evening over there, but have a nice
evening or afternoon.
>> Thank you, man.
>> I'mma go to sleep right now. I'm on one
HP. Thank you for your new point of
views. And
>> I'll see you next week, man.
>> Yes, sir. Next week.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> All right. Peace,
>> man. you know, there's there's, you
know, not not everybody is going to just
be able to snap and and and accept
things right on the spot. You know, some
people you're going to have to really
work. You're going to have to really
work with. So, that's why I was that
patient with him and I'm open to him
coming back and us finishing this so
that um we can see, you know, um that
that's that's that's what I'm here for,
to do the work, man. to really work with
people, you know, to really work with
people and even when they don't, you
know, accept something at face value
really really quick. Some do, but rare,
actually, rarely people do, right?
Rarely do people are going to, you know,
what? Yeah, that's that's that's wrong.
You know, that's it. I I can't do this.
I'm not a Muslim anymore. No, that's
rare. We get that sometimes, but
sometimes we got to get those people
that got to keep coming back and we got
to keep drilling in, you know, keep
drilling it into them, you know, until
they're like, "Okay, that's it." So,
thank you everybody for coming through,
man. I appreciate you guys, man. God
bless you guys. Please pray for me. Um,
pray for my patience and endurance and
longsuffering. Um, pray for the
ministry. Pray for the for my wife. Pray
for us all, man. I pray for you guys,
too, man. I love y'all, man.